at a high level our mission as a company
is to eliminate crime
i'm an engineer i took a look at this
problem from an engineering perspective
of
why does crime exist it exists because
it's easy to get away with
right only one in 10 non-violent crimes
actually leads in an arrest
and that's what's reported that doesn't
take out all the crime that might have
happened to you that you never even
called 911 because maybe
you weren't going to file an insurance
claim and so and certainly in san
francisco people have given up
they've been very explicit that they're
no longer even calling it in
which is sad in my opinion because if
you look at the primary research and
this is not
garrett's opinion or fox opinion this is
federally funded research on the topic
the only way to reduce crime is to solve
more of it
if you increase the opportunity cost of
being a criminal to a certain point
where you know you're going to get
arrested
you go get a real job like these people
could go get real jobs but they choose
to be a criminal because they know they
can get away with it so
our point of view out of the gate was
let's go build
really cool technology that actually
drives the likelihood of an arrest
occurring
and in doing that we believe long term
we'll see crime reductions that's what
we're seeing today so
that was four years ago when we started
the company you fast forward to today
we typically serve two types of
customers municipalities
and then the constituents inside of
those municipalities and a pretty cool
stat for you i was
shocked when i heard this one out of
every 100 arrests that will happen this
year
will be due to a flock camera one out of
every hundred arrests in the united
states will happen because a flaw camera
how many just ballpark cameras are out
there
how many communities are covered if we
were to think about a percentage of the
united states
um or percentage of major cities give us
an idea of of of what your footprint is
today
uh four years into your company yeah so
we're at almost about a 10 percent
coverage of cities in the country
that's where the actual city is a
customer it ranges from
smaller towns like a danville or san
marino
or la habra to bigger cities like a
memphis tennessee or
indianapolis or fort worth
so every and everyone in between um wow
uh so 10 and you have put a price point
on these that is extremely low
i was looking into these uh prior to you
existing and they were all custom
solutions that would have cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
implement in a neighborhood
if a neighborhood was going to spend a
half million dollars on security guards
and camera systems you could essentially
do a better job with your big data
license plate recognition than those
guards could
for 10 of the price how do you pitch it
when you're talking to those local
communities
yeah so that was me i was you jason just
a few years ago in my neighborhood
was a massive victim of crime an
organized gain came in
broke into every single car it was a
pretty terrible
weekend and when the police department
showed up they said look we don't have
any evidence you need a license plate
reader so we went to go procure them
a quarter of a million dollars later i
was like this doesn't compute i have
this 300 400 device an iphone in my
pocket it's got an incredible camera
it's got an lce modem it's got a cpu
that can do
computer vision why does this camera
cost forty thousand dollars
and so a buddy of mine and i put our
heads together said great i'm an
electrical engineer
let's go grab some of these old phones
off of you know the internet
tear them apart put them in a waterproof
box
put a solar panel on top and like lo and
behold with some good software and some
good computer vision you've built a
license plate reader
at a couple hundred dollar bomb and that
really hasn't fundamentally changed if
you look at a product today
it's gotten a lot better we're much
smarter engineers than than me working
on it now but it is still
really that's the a year or two behind
the best-in-class smartphone and we can
take off that supply chain
put it in our own custom package with a
managed service behind it and to your
point
whether you live in a hundred thousand
dollar home or a 10 million dollar home
your community can afford this and
that's i think i know you're a fan of
uber
i think that's something similar which
is like they made black
service type cars affordable for
everybody literally and i think that's
the goal of technology and i think
that's our safety buddies everybody's
private driver was the original tagline
um so you build this people start going
crazy for it for people who don't know
bomb is build of material so
essentially you've taken a smartphone
put it in a box
it's got a solar panel obviously it's
not a smartphone but it's literally
built off the components that are in
there so you
literally can install this in ten
minutes at any home
anywhere that has uh i'm assuming a four
or five g connection
and uh it's 200 bucks a month now
when i open up the interface what do i
see
and then i guess how specific can i get
in tracking
so yeah tell us what we see in the
display when you open up this
web-based tool because i've seen some
screenshots of it on
your website but i couldn't find an
actual demo of it on youtube or anywhere
yeah so there's really two primary use
cases there's a proactive
kind of solution and then a reactive
solution so proactive is strictly for
law enforcement so the cameras are
integrated into the fbi's
national database of wanted vehicles so
that's about a quarter million
cars that are stolen outstanding
warrants
amber alerts silver alerts like if
you're objectively a car that needs to
be pulled over
we know and so if you jason put a camera
in your front yard
and car drives by and it is on that list
within a few seconds
we've notified the nearest patrol
vehicle that to me is like that's why i
have one of my friends wow i have
two kids in my house i want to make sure
that if a stolen car drives by like
they're not saying any good yeah let me
let me sure understand this okay so a
stolen car goes by
my camera picks it up do i as the
homeowner
who pay for this 2500 get the alert as
well
or do you just do anot hey
this camera that we have on the network
and then you send it to
the local authorities and you have their
email address or you do a phone your
mechanical turket how do you actually
get that information
to the local you know community so for
the
the 13 plus 100 cities where we contract
with them
it goes directly into the patrol vehicle
so our software also runs in all the
patrol vehicles
so if you lived in san ramon um
and you steal a car and you drive by one
of the hundreds of cameras we have in
san ramon
whether it's owned by an individual a
neighborhood a small business owner or
the police department not license plate
or does it actually give them a video
clip with a gif or something
full video the license plate zoomed in
it's very important you talk about some
of the things that we take seriously
like one is
the objectivity and actionability of the
product and so we want to make sure
that's human verified because we think
our ml is great but
it's not perfect and so we pull up a
nice zoomed in image and say hey
we believe this is the state this is the
ocr
this is the exact license plate it
matches what the fbi says and then they
rerun that
in their own because we don't we see
warrant right hey there's an outstanding
warrant we don't know that's a violent
warrant or non-violent and so they'll
pull it up
and then what's pretty incredible is
most
police officers work really hard and so
when you give them a powerful tool like
this
they're on it they get pretty excited
they're all over it um so that's like
the number one use case
optical character recognition and so
what you're pointing out there i think
if i can
interpret for you hey maybe you know
you think this is a california plate but
it's got mud on it or it's a one or an
l and it's a dirty plate or you could
have
uh i would think fake plates as well or
there could be bad data in the system
there's so many things that can go wrong
and
the worst case scenario for you would be
to misidentify
mom coming home with her kids from pizza
and it's a stolen vehicle and cops then
you know surround the vehicle and god
forbid something bad were to happen so
you have to be very careful and say we
suspect this is
a car you should go do your diligence
and that's what the
ml team we have is like world caliber
and
unlike a traditional use case where it's
like hey if you're 85 it's fine
we recognize the responsibility we've
been given which is
when we say this is what it is it's
going to lead to an arrest it's a 99.9
confidence interval if you don't have
insurance you failed one of the first
steps of being an entrepreneur
and in broker's technology saves you
time and money prices are up to 20
percent lower
with better coverage than the incumbents
and you can go from sign up
to quote and purchase in just 10 minutes
when you work within broker instead of
business insurance incumbents
you're not dealing with these large slow
corporations and
sign up only takes days not weeks the
process is transparent with no
opaque pricing and there are four
crucial types of startup insurance that
they cover and that you need cyber
insurance
this is in case you get hacked dno
insurance this is for directors and
officers
if somebody does something dumb and you
get sued then there's eno insurance
some people haven't heard of this other
people know it all too well it's called
errors intermissions and it helps you
scale your business because any major
customer
will want you to have errors in emission
insurance when you close the deal and
finally and sadly epl
employment practices liability this
covers harassment wrongful termination
and more
if you are running a business and you
hit any kind of scale
somebody is going to do either do
something stupid or somebody is going to
feel
that they were wrongfully terminated
even if they were terrible and you fired
them with cause they can go find an
attorney to sue you you need to have epl
and you need to have all four of these
types of insurance if you're going to
become
venture backable and you're going to
build a robust business instantly buy
custom built insurance for startups go
to inbroker.com
twist e-m-b-r-o-k-e-r-dot-com
twist in broker.com twist and use my
offer code twist to get 10
off